hello and welcome to a game spot news
ama you can ask me anything you like
about the elder scrolls online launch
dates because that's information that I
said forward have for you right now the
elder scrolls online developer ZeniMax
online studios recently held a reddit
ask me anything where they announced the
exact times players will be able to
enter the pc version of its new
massively multiplayer online
role-playing game the game will
officially launch on April fourth at
midnight in the UK but early access
players will be able to get in five or
three days earlier five day early access
we'll begin on Sunday March 30th while
three day early access we'll start on
Tuesday April first all launches will be
simultaneous with local timing as
follows North America East will be live
at seven a.m. EDT the UK at 12pm Central
Europe at 1pm Australia at 10pm aedt and
Singapore at seven p.m. sgt as the
official launch there's a 12 hour shift
with the east coast of america going
live at seven p.m. EDT on april the
third with the rest of the world in on
april the force UK at midnight central
europe at 1am australia at ten a.m. aedt
and singapore at seven a.m. sgt again
this works out to be exactly the same
time no matter where you are if you're a
ps4 or xbox one gamer you'll be waiting
until june i'm afraid the Elder Scrolls
online will be retailing at sixty
dollars with a fifteen dollar monthly
fee which Bethesda claims is necessary
for what it calls significant updates
it's not a ridiculous amount to be
spending on an MMO and will you be
sticking with regular old Skyrim until
we get an elder scrolls six if so
gamespot's got you covered with its top
5 skyrim mods of the week series filling
you in on how to keep Skyrim as fresh as
that justin bieber he's a genie in a
bottle stick around for more food
gamespot
you